why don't you believe in original ideas
that's a great question I do
um there's a lot of ways to put that uh
I do
believe I do believe in original ideas
um can you Market something toward a
broader audience on original idea it's a
lot tougher um and what I mean by that
is when you're thinking of a screenplay
or a project from a commercial
perspective
um you know a lot of screenwriters don't
do this is that when they're first
starting out they don't the story is all
important and for me the foundation of a
good film is still a tremendously you
know inspiring well structured blueprint
you know the screenplay if it's not a
good screenplay I'm not sure how you can
think it would be a good film um and so
that's still all important but the idea
of looking at your at at product and
your own ideas and saying well where
does it fit you know um if I'm looking
at taking on a
project other than the elements you know
the actors the director the you know uh
who who are The Producers the package
itself where does this fit you know what
is the budget range you know how much
money am I going to have to uh spend
marketing this and where do I do that um
and I think I think for me the original
idea is still certainly in play but
sometimes especially in markets like
horror for
instance those audiences go to those
movies and there's a certain kind of
understanding they know what they're
going to get but if you can put an
original Twist on an you know an older
idea then you've got something one I
know how to Market it and two oh there's
a there's something original for
instance talk to me recently from the
philippo brothers that came out in the
theaters uh tremendous movie scary loved
it and I've seen so much horror it's
it's not easy to get scared anymore but
um that movie is is for me you know
deconstructing it a little too much
probably is it's Ouija it's a Ouija
board movie but with a hand right it has
the same tropes to a certain degree it
has that those same scares but it's got
an original Twist on the idea and we
hadn't seen that before I hadn't seen
that before so that's I think
originality from that perspective is
something you can indulge but also
keeping in the back of your mind that
someone buying your film has to find a
way to Market it right a holy you know
original idea is a lot harder to Market
than it is with something that we might
recognize fits somewhere but there's an
original Twist on it and I think so to
answer your question yes originality
still exists but how do I Market that I
think to you've talked about loving The
Exorcist probably the briest film of all
time right and and the thing is it's so
much of like this fear of the unknown
you don't even have to show you know
whatever happens it there's such fear
and suspense and it's kind of ingrained
in us even if we're not religious
exactly and I think that it's film
making as well um when you look at that
movie and you look at um the first
Paranormal Activity movie um what is
special about that movie is there's no
monsters there's no Gore there's none of
that it's just terrifying because we can
relate to it you know with those the
scenes of those two people in bed and
that Open Door what what's going to come
through that I I don't know and that's
terrifying nothing really comes through
it until the end spoiler alert sorry
about that um but but movies like that
are what I find original and terrifying
in the horror genre ones that exploit
that tension in the film making itself
um and and I think the exodist has that
as well you never know what you're going
to get when when you know Ellen bur's
character and the priests walk back into
that room you don't and I think that the
longer you can hold that before you
enter that room you know that's just
dramatic effect um and so I think that's
why the Exorcist to me even today is not
dated it's still a relevant film and in
fact this weekend just gone I was at
horac con where I met Linda Blair for
the first time she was at horac con I
geeked out and I got a photo with her I
couldn't help myself so but the exist
you know it it for me it transcends
horror it's simply good film making and
tremendous character relationships bound
up in just wanting to help this young
girl escape this evil you know which has
been echoed and echoed and echoed
throughout a lot of horror movies but
just brilliantly crafted by the late
great Billy freaken for sure and I think
they did a remake recently correct or
it's com out Friday okay that's what I
thought you talk yeah we'll see how that
holds up I'm scared and not by the film
I I'm scared that it won't be good um I
haven't heard anything so I don't know
um I'm planning to go Friday to see it
just to see what they've done but how do
you Rec recreate something like that I I
don't I don't think they're looking to
do that first of all but at the same
time what they're doing is they're
tapping into to a really well-known
popular IP that transcends its period in
the hopes of drawing that crowd and a
new crowd to that particular uh movie so
they can restart a franchise we'll see
how successful they are but um um I I
have High Hopes but that usually gets me
in trouble well it's similar to music
you know like I didn't know that mly
crew didn't do smoking in the boy room
it was already done before or Whitney
Houston I'm Every Woman Shaka KH had
done it so each generation has its own
like Superstar song that they didn't
realize was done previous generation so
right and the writers are benefiting
from a reboot of that you know um I mean
Kate Bush is a good example with
stranger things right you know she
rarely gives away rights to any of her
music and I'm I've got every album so
I'm a huge fan um but I think that there
are opportunities there for people to
redo that I
talk about originality I I I wish there
was a lot more originality and not
rehashing that in the sampling age that
we've come into but I also find myself
liking that too so you know um I think
there is an Artistry to doing that
really well what do you think about
stealing
ideas from previous movies is there a
right way to do it or a wrong way or
it's just as as a as a rule it's well
something we shouldn't do I think EX
dealing is a very explosive term um how
do you do that uh I think that's been
almost the Crux of what these negot the
strike negotiations have been about is
how do we how do we look at the
evolution of AI and not talk about
stealing ideas in order to reformat them
into something else um I've rarely seen
in my time anything stolen like that I'm
sure it does happen um but borrowing
from other movies you know there's a
whole genre that's parody you know um uh
I'm helping develop a parody of a
slasher movie at the moment that's
that's really clever in the way that
it's done but um the idea of taking the
slasher movie and turning it into
something else you know and maybe not
genre but you can use parts of movies to
refer
to but I guess I I would wonder what you
mean by stealing stealing other movies
and into something else sure well if you
even see it on YouTube a lot of uh
people do very similar videos or similar
titles uh you know it's become a new
thing and I'm sure it's the same as done
as music so it's not like say a remake
where you do a star is born and you have
new actors in it but just something
where it's almost not credited and it's
it's remade yeah it's hard to it's hard
we have you know Studios have entire
rights departments always monitoring
that kind of thing piracy you know stuff
that shouldn't be on those and I think
YouTube has become a lot better about
that about taking those down when they
occur um it's very hard to stop but I
think um I think a lot of the times you
know distinguishing between stealing
something and wanting to wanting it to
be an homage to something there's a very
fine line to that and I you know it's
becoming much tougher to police I think
um when something is created
uh taking it and turning it into
something else that lacks of ality that
lacks
imagination and so you know if you're
someone who's involved in doing that um
you know my advice would be try to do
something original you know but with a
Twist you know something like that but I
think stealing other people's idea in
any kind of art form is pretty
low